[Music]
okay this one's kind of sad guys
we can do it i'll make it funny come on
let's go i don't think you should
no we'll make fun of them we'll make fun
of them don't worry sometimes we can be
like
humans you know sometimes yeah but
humans make fun of things that you're
not supposed to that's human to cope to
cope or you could just like cry
i'm just like have a catharsis let's
have a 12 minute cry episode
i basically will feel really healthy
afterwards but i don't want to hug
though because of corona
no story not because it's corona food
social distance
we got a socially distance
we're six feet apart six feet from just
the camera makes things look closer than
they actually are yeah we're me in case
you're actually
takes away the distance we actually
edited it in right now
okay wait no okay hold on this is a sad
story
this is um this is about chrissy teigen
and john legend
yeah they lost their baby she had a
miscarriage right yeah well we don't
know
this is why they say don't even reveal
that you're pregnant until you're
actually
[ __ ] good that is what i want to talk
about we need to talk about that but in
a second
oh okay so chrissy she uh
so she was pregnant with her third baby
her previous two
babies like luna and miles so they
were through ivf but this baby
who they named jack he was a naturally
conceived
and not through in vitro fertilization
oh that's what ivf stand for yeah but
even with the other two
kids she did have complications in the
pregnancy
but with jack her placenta just wasn't
working properly what do you mean so
that's where the baby gets nutrients and
stuff and so
that like it was apparently she was
bleeding a lot
before this tragic loss and so she was
going in and getting blood transfusions
and like she just wasn't able to provide
enough blood
for the baby so we don't know if the
baby was born a stillborn or if the baby
was born
was alive for a period of time and then
passed
but um the point is like she was halfway
through her pregnancy by the way
so she still had the other half to go oh
geez she was underdeveloped too
like the baby was just like four months
in five months
something like that so when you have a
miscarriage does that mean that the baby
passes inside and then it just like your
body goes
it's time to release man yeah well yeah
i don't know
the exact difference because the
stillborn is like when the baby's
born not alive so technically that means
that they
passed inside too i don't know what the
difference i thought it was like
i shouldn't call it a stillborn though
it should be called a not born or
something more sensitive unborn
yeah that's that's bad unborn sounds
very zombie-ass it does
rain check with the name yeah let me
check chrissy she recently posted
on her instagram account these photos
she's so sad
who are these photos of the process
and i'll read to you her caption which
is absolutely heartbreaking do you think
that
they hired a photographer for this
moment so that's what people are also
criticizing well
we'll hold on right because because they
didn't
assume the baby to pass right well
that's oh it was early yeah oh
that would make sense where it's like
it's a scheduled kind of thing
and then like the photographer was there
and you wanted to get a good close-up
of that baby popping out of that [ __ ]
and it's like magical moments
happy moments in this case it was they
knew that it was a
miscarriage no so the thing is
they knew that there were complications
this is all as
my own assumption is that they probably
had a photographer come in hoping that
the baby would survive outside of them
and then they can like celebrate the
birth right but then unfortunately it
ended up
being a tragic moment and then the fact
that chrissy
like she's really open with her life
like since the beginning
or not the beginning of pregnancy but by
the time that the world knew that she
was pregnant she was pretty open about
the fact that it was a high risk
pregnancy
and she was bed written to a point where
she stopped working
and she was just trying to do her best
to
to do what she can for this baby so this
is her caption can i make a joke real
quick
okay fine okay i just put myself in the
photographer's shoes
and it's like oh my god they're having a
miscarriage and she's like wait
capture this moment and then he starts
going
[Music]
and he's taking pictures or if it's like
i'm taking pictures of nicki and she's
like i'm gonna do a different angle like
this is horrible like [ __ ] stand up a
little
taller and like like look down don't do
this [ __ ] where you got me [ __ ] dead
on don't do that [ __ ] i know right and
it's like
how awkward is it that's how people
perceive it right
like with your perspective you see it as
awkward
a lot it's a cynical view a lot of
people share that same view
um but other people are just like hey
man like
people grieve differently people grieve
openly and maybe that gives them
closure whatever it is and i don't even
think that's wrong i'm just thinking how
awkward would it be to be that
photographer you know what's great about
this actually is that miscarriages
happen all the time
and that she's kind of showing like the
pain of it that people don't see
the positives exactly like what people
are like
a lot of a lot of women who have gone
through this or that empathize with
other women that have gone through or
what men and women they say like
you know the reason why there there's
that rule like going back to what you
were saying how there's like the
three-month rule where you're not
supposed to say
that you're pregnant because there's
always that possibility that you might
lose and you have to go face
the pain of like telling the news that
you lost the baby or whatever it is and
that you jinxed it
some people think that you will be like
dude you prematurely told man
[ __ ] jinxed it right so then that
part like a lot of people
people really do think that though yeah
so a lot of people find that that
mentality is really
messed up because it's like you know
what like
miscarriages are a really common thing
unfortunately it's a really common
thing and the the more people like keep
it in
and like don't talk about it then the
worse it is for
a lot of people that end up going
through this is because they can't talk
about they end up grieving
in silence and there's no support and
there's just like
there's no there's yeah it's just a
really lonely experience but i really
want to read this caption though well
real quick for as much people love to
come all over america's healthcare
system and say it's the best in the
world or whatever
we have like a higher rate of
miscarriages and
and like silver stillborns and all that
kind of stuff that
many developed countries do why that's
an interesting fact actually
yeah i didn't expect that problem in
developing countries
then many developing countries don't we
also have way more c-sections than any
other country
you guys i recommend you guys all watch
the business of being born in the
documentary by ricky lake she breaks it
off ricky lake i miss her
me too she was a she had a dope ass talk
show man yeah dope ass documentary you
should watch it i'll watch it
i already know that c-sections they're
way quicker way faster way cleaner all
that stuff
it's cost-efficient so they push people
to do that it's more dangerous that's
why more women die
no i mean like it's it's more it makes
more money because the doctors can go
through this it's just like getting it
out like i felt like
i felt like [ __ ] cattle when i was
getting a c-section and then they always
recommend it saying it's better for you
and it doesn't destroy your [ __ ] so you
should do it that way hairdressers did
that to ricky later in the 90s they said
the bob haircut is going to be great for
you it's going to work for you
they could just cut it and get it out
and we'll get it done with it but then
it actually would destroy her entire
life in her career
just one bad haircut guys you just so
you guys you started the care and
haircut trend all it takes
okay before i read this caption let me
give you some statistics so it says in
the united states about 10 to 20
of known pregnancies end in miscarriage
my cousin had like a lot like a lot but
she has three kids now yeah
also uh the country records about 26
000 still births every year
meaning that one in 160 pregnancies that
last at least 20 weeks ends with
the death of a baby before delivery
that's what that means
so is there a reason why like our
country is
worse when it comes to like keeping the
baby our health care system is hyped up
bro
it's not as sick as everyone likes to
say it is yeah
well is it because it's like prenatal
sucks
or like what what is it that's killing
the babies or
is it the mom's health is it like
because yeah
i think it's so expensive that a lot of
people who are in [ __ ] situations
they can't go to the doctor for all this
prenatal all this [ __ ] they
they can't go for all the all the like
work that has to get done beforehand and
like making sure everything's on track
they go when it's too late and so then
when they're delivering
they're already in a situation where
they didn't have the right vitamins and
all kinds of [ __ ]
to help the baby grow and all this stuff
so they're just going because it's an
emergency and they have to deliver
and so that's why so other countries
that are considered like
more broke than we are just have better
like other countries that aren't killing
it
economically like we are quote unquote
right like they have
like a health care system that lets them
go to the doctor
anytime because they don't have to worry
about the crazy bills
because everyone knows if you go to the
doctor here you're
you're gonna get a huge huge bill you go
there and you go
oh man my elbow hurt a little bit and
you have a bill for like two thousand
dollars
exactly you break your [ __ ] arm and
it's like a couple grand
how about when you let the doctor touch
your balls and they should be paying you
but you end up paying them i've always
wondered that one yeah they even asked
you to cough
and they get an extra it's like man you
got to [ __ ] touch my balls dude you
should be paying me
okay well let me bring it back and
should they be paying us though to touch
our balls
no i wanted to read this caption it says
we are in shock and in the kind of deep
pain you only hear about the kind of
pain
we've never felt before we were never
able to stop the bleeding
because she said it was like a like a
water faucet like slowly leaking
like that's how much and then she says
um we were never able to stop the
bleeding and give our baby the fluids he
needed despite
bags and bags of blood transfusions it
just wasn't enough
we never decided on our babies names
until the last possible moment after
they're born just before we leave the
hospital but we
for some reason had started to call this
little guy in my belly jack
so he will always be jack to us jack
worked so hard to be part of our little
family and he will be
forever to our jack i'm so sorry that
the first few moments of your life were
met with so many complications
which makes it sound like he was born
alive that we couldn't
give you the home you needed to survive
we will always love you
thank you to everyone who has been
sending us positive energy thoughts and
prayers we feel all of your love and
truly appreciate you we are so grateful
for the life we have
for our wonderful babies luna and miles
for all the amazing things we've been
able to experience
but every day can't be full of sunshine
on this darkest of days we will grieve
we will cry our eyes out but we will hug
and love each other
harder and get through it she ended up
tweeting out to
something along the lines of like uh
leaving the hospital without a baby
is like i saw that one that was horrible
but i just think that naming it
the naming is unfortunate because when
you say i didn't have jack
like that's like a loss that's that's
crazy it makes it a little different
that's that's crazy i was uh i was
actually just listening to
uh i was good i wasn't my girl listening
to i have to try i know right i think i
don't know it was a ig story or
something like that where she was
actually talking about
a couple days right before no she had
been open
yeah she was open about it and and i was
just catching uh this
what she was talking about she was very
open she was talking about how she was
bleeding but
that the baby was still okay yeah and
then it was like literally like two days
later that i
had heard this news and it is just so
interesting to
be because i obviously i don't know her
as a person but to be like
aware of somebody's i guess what we
would consider in society yes
such a personal journey and experience
and then obviously to even like
have it end in heartbreak um it does
touch on that theme that we were
discussing earlier about like people
being more open
about like these types of things that
happen so commonly to women
because like this is uh even the idea or
the conversations of miscarriage is like
so taboo even amongst like your closest
friends you know what i mean so even as
a
male i don't even know how to reach out
to certain people that have experienced
it so like
ask them about it without thinking that
maybe it just feels insensitive right
because i feel the same thing but this
article here is from the washington post
it's actually pretty helpful it does
give advice
on like how to be there for someone that
you know that is going through this
so i recommend you guys read it um it's
yeah it's like you just never really
know like
like i want to be there for you but i
don't know i don't want to do the wrong
thing
so you kind of end up feeling paralyzed
but when i was a kid and my cousin had a
miscarriage and she had like a lot a lot
every time she did i was like oh are you
going to try again i want another nephew
yeah that's one i was a kid like i
didn't i don't know
yeah but grown adult people say like oh
it's okay don't worry you'll get over it
just keep trying
like that's not helpful yeah it's not
they don't know what to do though
yeah exactly well because think about
dude and not to get too serious but when
you think about
her going through all of this you find
out you're pregnant like you go through
the whole thing you're doing all this
[ __ ] and then at the end of it
like you don't get to meet the kid like
that's
horrible so heartbreaking but honestly
people are calling
chrissy and john like heroes for being
outspoken about
their grief because it is helping a lot
of people that are also going through
this and
helping them feel less alone
[Music]
you